oh and wait you called me from your
watch i called you for one
first of all being able to make phone
calls from your apple watch is
the most power ranger [ __ ] that you can
do
i'm like driving i'm like hello hello
it made me cody come in yeah
there's an issue at the tmg studio i'll
be their stat
no you have to touch your you have to
touch your air pod and speak into your
yeah into your apple watch
i'm on my way yeah so um
my i bust my phone and
i'm making calls cause people are
texting me and stuff and i'm like i
can't
respond to anything and i'm making calls
from my phone and i said
why do i need a phone i just have this
thing oh yeah maybe you just want to
cruise through a
just like a grocery store or something
you're like yeah yeah and then i said
totally
just out loud yeah dude she sucked my
[ __ ] off dude
no i'm not kidding man she really sucked
it dude sucked it for some reason
it's like the hand position is worse to
me than
speaking on speaker because on speaker
having some [ __ ] on speakers like this
person really doesn't give a [ __ ] but
apple watch speaker is like you man
you're really trying to be annoying
[Laughter]
to the base dude she went to the base
[ __ ] that'd be a great milk prank
oh yeah they gotta do that one also just
standing beside a dude
at a grocery store and being like dude
tell she sucked my [ __ ] here tell them
and holding your watch up to this guy
what's your name
yeah i've never had you know
that to me was the most tech experience
i've had in my life this feature is dumb
as hell
what is calling from your watch
like yeah
i mean clearly it's helpful in one
situation i think that's why they made
it it's for that exact situation
yeah when people smash their incredibly
fragile phones do you have a crack in
your phone yet
i the very first day i had it i was
riding the scuzza
yeah and uh by the way guys is
one of those bikes from the uh the no
flex music video
yeah did i tell you about the leaning
thing yeah yeah yeah i told you about
that yeah
yeah so the very first day i had i think
it was that day i was cruising around
thinking that
i was like thought i looked cool and
then my phone
flew out of my pocket and just landed on
the ground like
literally right after i unpackage it you
want to know what else
i lost my macbook pro charger and then
i lost my earpods and so i switched back
to my old airpods
and i just i was gonna go for a run
yesterday and i opened the case
and they're not in there i lost those
too
i'm just a piece of [ __ ] i can't i'm
almost 30.
i'm 30 now why can't i handle my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
man some 30 year old birthday bro
i [ __ ] i'm 30 i can't even find my
airbox dude
who am i i'm a mess
oh man dude yeah um
i just can't wait for this cursed ass
experience to be over
so we can hit next week fresh and right
and
i'm moving tomorrow well between
oh let's hope to god that's not cursed
no you know what bro
that's the one that's the pot that's a
positive i mean
that's a positive thing for positive
things today but
the um shout out shout out to
my my contractor bro yeah
shout out to my contractor i'm saying
big things we're coming up
we got contractors
inside of my contractor shout out my
contractor
shout out my security lady she's hot
yo big shout out my electrician yeah he
hooks it up man
my electricity timers and everything so
far electrician is fire dude
so far
so fire dog
uh yeah so shout out to my contractor
what did he do
why are you shouting him out no he just
give him this
no no but no
he's just like we didn't we didn't have
too much going on in our place but
it was basically a recommendation like
yo dude you have these random odds and
ends
that are like just one step above a
handyman it requires some people
um but you know basically
we got a recommendation so you know this
guy's awesome and he'll take care of it
and we hit him up and he's like yeah i
got some time
so i told him about my panel my studio
panels
because i was really dreading having to
spend
any money i'm like god [ __ ] we're moving
i don't want to whatever
so i call him and he's like oh yeah i
can move those no problem
and he made him work in the new space
and so we went up to the new spot and
it's just like my studio is going to
move like clean
so episode next week for sure wait what
you're using the same panels
and it works yep works oh what that's
sick
yeah just just clean oh that's so nice
oh my god that's a blessing
that's a blessing the guy the guy that
came through and did this was like yeah
you could sell your old panels there's
tons of people looking for these right
now
because everyone's i guess trying to
like treat their rooms because
a lot of music being made right now yeah
and um oh yeah and everyone's working
from home yeah probably for resume
actually i don't know
i was like how much can i get for these
things like probably 100 bucks a pop
i listed them on craigslist offer me up
everything nothing not a single [ __ ]
hit no no
i can't believe you know what's so funny
that guy goes you can sell him a hundred
apiece how much are you selling them for
bro oh we're doing them like six
six hundred eighty yeah yeah so many
people need these it's crazy i get calls
for this every day
people need my service yeah yeah no
we sell them for way we [ __ ] you guys
yeah because you need these so we [ __ ]
you
i had another guy come spec out my uh
my new spot and you know what
crazy thing my my new place my new
office is a little bit smaller but
i kind of like it more i kind of like it
more
yeah i was listening to um or i was
watching one of my old videos as i do
i watch all my own [ __ ] all the time go
back and watch
how funny i used to be and um
the audio is a lot better in my old
studio i noticed because
it's just smaller yep and the treatment
was better
it's like being in a closet with a bunch
of clothes like the audio in there is
the best it could ever be so if you're
if you're at home right now listening
to our podcast and and you have an itch
to be creative and you've been thinking
like uh but i need but no you don't
no you don't yeah okay tim the tatman
does it in a six by seven room
[Laughter]
and now bro there's so many acoustic
panels on [ __ ] craigslist what the
[ __ ]
everyone's trying to dump them that's
that's good that's good news
you